hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Xbox 1x has officially been revealed
and I have to check it out it's a great
piece of kit but if you're like me and
don't have any desire to switch over to
the Microsoft platform then I have seven
reasons why you should be happy about
the Xbox one egg from a player she's
done quite feel free to let your inner
fanboy out in the comments below but try
to be civil monopoly you've probably
played this as a child and turned over a
table in disgust or maybe that's just my
family well this word is extremely
important in competitive markets taught
bluntly when one company has control
over an entire area of the market it can
cause development to stop and things
tend to stay the same here's a few
examples the iPhone was a design
masterpiece with innovation at its core
the improvements kept is coming back for
more until Apple pretty much ruled the
roost in the smartphone world fast
forward a few years and the choice to
stay on iphone in 2017 is a difficult
decision to muster with Android and
manufacturers like Samsung offering
arguably higher quality products with
innovation at the core again and quite
regularly a cheaper price point - if
you're not a mobile phone enthusiast and
I have a second example the WWE it may
just be my opinion but the current WWE
is a shadow of its former self and I am
certain this is because they bought out
all their serious opposition when WCW on
WWF went head-to-head in the ratings war
they were forced to innovate and give
fans what they wanted thus creating a
competitive environment in which the
consumer was king I believe this is why
we need Xbox back in the console war
competition is great for us and we'll
get as more bang for our book and more
cuisine - speaking of money one of the
best things the PlayStation community
can hope for after the release of the
Xbox one X is a price drop on the ps4
Pro the One X has come in at a crazy
high price of a console gaming and Sony
could really take advantage of this by
dropping the price of their PlayStation
product The One X retails at 499 dollars
and the PlayStation 4 Pro at 390
if they could find a way to take $50 off
the fro price then that will cause no
end of problems for Microsoft's mid
generation upgrades are still a new
notion in console gaming PC gamers have
always been prepared to upgrade RAM
occasionally buy a new mouse when they
smash it into pieces and other bits of
technology to achieve superior
performance and gain an edge over other
gamers but the great thing about console
gaming is the general fact that we are
all equal this is like if the changing
gears to come as those playing on the
Xbox one X will have a distinct
advantage over those who remain on the
110 this isn't solely an Xbox issue
either as I've seen firsthand the
problems that occur when ps4 players go
up against ps4 pro players on
battlefield one in battlefield one the
framerate changes depending on the
workload of the machines the standard
ps4 does a stellar job and frequently
achieves forty five-plus frames a second
but the pro achieves sixty regularly
it's when explosions are on screen and
sixty-four players are dashing about and
a few vehicles too that you really see
the standard ps4 significantly
underperform when compared to the pro
these shots are from digital foundry
they show that the pro gives you an
advantage on the battlefield the
smoother frame rates the higher quality
visuals put bluntly you would need
faster reflexes if you're playing on a
base PlayStation 4 as I'm writing this
the Xbox 1x users are frantically
requesting destiny to is made 60 frames
per second but even though I don't think
this will happen if it did then you guys
on a standard Xbox one would be ripped
to pieces in PvP as you are locked at 30
frames a second I'm aware that there are
so many more factors contributing to
this but ultimately we are no longer
equal by the way I'm deliberately
staying away from teraflops and overly
technical terms that scare me a little
bit if I'm honest but I recommend
digital foundry if you're in a techno
geek wants more information the real
kicker in the new console war are those
console exclusives Microsoft are
frantically trying to win back many
developers as they are hugely behind in
this front don't get me wrong they have
some damn good exclusives but nothing
near those associated to play stage
god of war spider-man gran turismo
horizon zero dawn uncharted oh and days
gone too and that's just off the top of
my head
that's not even everything that was
covered at e3 2017 the list must go on
and credit to Microsoft they are
attempting to close that void the next
point is about 4k this is a peculiar one
to fathom let's start with the facts not
all ps4 pro games are true for K in fact
hardly any ps4 pro games are true for K
this is definitely Xboxes biggest draw
so expect advertising to push that point
if you are able to spot the differences
between the two and it means something
to you then maybe you should be jumping
over to Xbox or buying a PC I know it's
not that simple but think about it I
personally cannot tell the difference
between true 4k and the pros for care
checkerboarding in the majority of cases
oh and so I don't look like a complete
gobshite here I'll state that I was part
of the BBC switch from standard
definition into high-definition so
although I'm no resolution guru I have
seen firsthand this area of format
change in the past what I like true 4k
damn right I would would I be willing to
pay $500 for it sadly no I wouldn't
that's a stretch too far for me
personally but we're all different
aren't we so please let me know what you
think here if you're feeling worried
that the pro isn't in the same league as
the xbox 1x and keep in mind
cross-platform development expect
developers to support the pro much more
now pushing the console further than it
has been pushed before as it becomes the
base that they all develop around
developers will double down on 4k
functionality if that's what the market
demands with the xbox 1x joining the ps4
Pro expect developers to begin to leave
the ps4 on the standard Xbox behind this
shouldn't ever mean that a game is only
playable on the latest models but the
quality levels will begin to drop up in
favor of creating the best experiences
on the pro on the X on the plus side
though those of you who have a pro
should see improvement in future games
which may have been difficult to notice
in recent games the rumor mill hints
that a ps4 Pro slim model will be coming
soon
and you never know if the Xbox one X
does better than
expected then the ps5 may be closer than
we think this is an opinion piece so if
you don't agree with me that's fine let
me know what I should be considering
below what do you think of the Xbox one
are you going to buy it are you going to
have both the ps4 Pro and the next box
1x who has that much money laying around
I really can't wait to see what happens
next
and I hope Microsoft have a success on
their hands I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade I'll see you next time